[Music]
you go to go to places all over the
world I've seen you at rallies in all
kinds of where you get the balls to do
it because a lot of the times I wait you
got someone throw pee on you once or
something it must be yeah I have an
answer the other thing that happens um
must uh you know sometimes I think it
might be stupidity like hey you're so
stupid Laurie why are you doing waves I
come from in you I I think it's just
something that I I remember the first
time I went and I did something like
that was at the [ __ ] walk in Vancouver
which was like my first no it's my
second like viral video I ever did and I
was sitting around soul Rizzo's shaking
like you can see me visibly shaking in
the video when I went out when I filed
that sign there's no rape culture unless
I was so nervous but it's not things we
just just do it just do it once we've
done it you will get the confidence and
it obviously it's gotten easier and
easier every time and now I kind of get
excited in those moments like I thrive
off of the I Drive off of the adrenaline
you know running in the crowd with anti
flower flashbangs are going off and
pepper spray everywhere you know it's me
you're getting you're getting a story
you're getting this out to people it's
just a really really cool experience to
me now of course there's the natural
fear that should have but I mean I never
fell to any point except maybe in
Milwaukee that I could die if I didn't
leave the situation that Milwaukee was
the only time I felt like we had to
leave or we might die how absolutely
insane was that cuz I had tim pool on do
you know Tim Tim yeah I seen him Sweden
right now I was just hanging out with it
right now are you sure okay yeah he's
another guy with balls that goes to
these places he tweeted and the reason I
had him on the show we did it last
minute I didn't know who he was but I
saw a tweet by this guy who said that
I'm an independent journalist and I
don't let up and I checked him out he
looked legit and his tweet was that this
I've been to Tahrir Square I've been to
Venezuela I've been to all these war
zones Milwaukee is the most I've ever
felt threatened I was there towards the
tail on the protest like they're still
going on when I got there I I haven't
told the story on camera yet but it was
one guy I went there with a couple of my
I didn't really know them that well but
a couple of micro out friends who
just through a backpack of blocks in the
back and they're like to the jungle we
go and they start driving this Humvee
they're carryin I've got them with me
and we get there and like there's
literally people putting on like
bulletproof vests and stuff when we show
up like there's bullet shells on the
ground it's crazy and the cops come up
to us and they're like because they can
usually tell when you're carrying right
are you guys carrying and the two guys
those was really nervous like Jack we're
caring and there's a cop literally
looked at us and said good good like
imagine a cops like being this good you
are carrying a weapon like you're white
you should be carrying a weapon here
good like you you are in an area where
you could get shot and killed for being
here
that was an insane experience and anyone
as a gun owner is probably sitting there
like what like I saw Lee want to
bookable yeah you hear that from a cop
again yeah but that's why I don't know
what what happened to the video with
that but we still have it somewhere I'm
sure were they they were coming up to us
and of course guys and masks and
everything get out of here or you're
going to get hurt get out of here you're
going to get hurt right and this was
when things weren't even that crazy
what were the cops doing though what
were they had today withstand hours I
mean what was happening that was
allowing for this insanity I mean
they're they've got such a tight leash
there was one guy who was causing
trouble back just got arrested do you
think it gets beat up hitting it shot
nothing just getting arrested and the
community that were around him were
screaming at the top of their lungs like
these actors hate ice they're racist
this time the other ending is just like
everything was so the it was also on
edge like it was about to blow up any
second right so the cops were like
standing often if any of those cops did
anything if they got into an altercation
trying to like stop these guys from
smashing stuff it could be national news
with a bounty on their head from black
lives matter so it's a very scary
situation for these people and it's it's
the it's such a sad situation because
being in that community and talking to
people there they were very documented
by the media like it's hard for me to go
there and say they are consciously
making these
stupid decisions right a lot of these
people are truly truly believed that
they are living in this white
supremacist society trying to bring them
down and of course there were people
within that community that I spoke to as
well that understood the indoctrination
of the community and really yeah I'm
living in a community of people that
have been totally indoctrinated to both
Democrat and have been totally
indoctrinated to believe this was a race
war that we're living in right now
right we should pause there for a second
because in most of these cities the
mayors are Democrat okay yeah Milwaukee
Chicago one of the other one of
gentlemen I spoke to there was like and
you said exactly that you think we've
had Democrats year-over-year and none of
these people notice that nothing gets
better yeah yeah yeah so how do you flip
that how do you actually show them that
this isn't what's right I sense actually
the Trump is actually going to be good
at it
which is why people are so angry at him
because he's already said I'm going to
go into the inner cities now I'm not for
federal overreach of doing it but I
think there's ways you can do things
he's going to work with Steve Harvey
everybody likes Steve article but
they're going to try to do some of this
stuff in the inner cities to clean it up
I mean that would be a great win it
would be a great win because it's the
the right thing to do sort of morally
and in terms of the country but it would
also be a great win for Trump personally
well obviously a lot of these people get
a lot of welfare and stuff right now now
these young men that were there that
I've run into there are a lot of young
kids running the street waiting for
things to happen like the stock to set
on fire so we could smash and get some
weave or whatever right and like these
young kids who come up to us and we had
our camera like yeah what kind of camera
is that like tell me about it
do you guys sell videos that we do and
you're really curious they're like you
know what kind of job do you do I'd love
to do kind of video stuff let me tell me
how you do that like really genuinely
curious to know about a career they
could go forward with and I mean there's
a viral video this is going to go into a
bit of a different category but this
rapper Meek Mill have you heard of him
okay he's mill he put out a viral video
recently where he makes a homeless guy
do 20 push-ups for 20 bucks and everyone
was infuriated the Internet blew up they
were like this is disgusting this is
awful this is why our you know what is
that better than what you're doing just
not giving them 20 bucks you're giving
it as letting them work
to get 20 bucks like what's wrong with
that what's the issue why not set up or
more Republican system where you these
kids are given jobs like bring jobs to
these community communities I mean they
burnt down the gas station because
they're convinced that's racist it burnt
down the city because they're convinced
the racism stop with these Democrat
tactics of race baiting telling them
they're all oppressed and giving them
free stuff give them opportunities I
mean I'm telling you the kids were
talking to me and they want that they
want a way out of there they want jobs
so clearly what you got going on right
now isn't working and just about
anything just about any change at all
can whether it's Trump as horrible as
they think he is shake things up a bit
because the current thing is making
making the situation a whole hell of a
lot worse yeah for all the things that
you said about Canada earlier how much
of this actually bleeds across the
border because we do live in this global
well now in every video that you put up
obviously crossing borders and all that
stuff but you know there was that thing
about a year ago at the gay pride parade
in Toronto where black lives matter
literally stopped the parade and
demanded that the organizers of the gay
parade sign there edik saying these are
the things we're going to do which they
eventually did because they were in a
hostage situation pretty much like they
weren't gonna let the parade move
forward but black lives matter has more
to do with policing in the United States
it had nothing to do with Toronto as far
as I know so how much of this just gets
up there just because of the nature of
the internet well we're the spoiled
brats but and I of course there are some
great Canadians in Alberta and
everything but not you okay yeah I don't
mean all Canadians there are some great
ones there but the spoiled brats of
Canada that don't have to deal with any
of these real issues but we don't have a
problem with cop on black violence we
don't have those issues well of course
it's gonna be the individuals but
certainly not even close to the states
right yet
spoiled little brat Canada looks good I
want to be a revolutionary too I want to
protest too so you've got I did a video
on black lives matter Toronto which with
a group that banned gay cops from
marching in there and from marching in
the Pride Parade and they've got the
nadir of that they so what was that the
same parade yeah at least allowed Idol
part of their those part of their thing
okay police officers who probably had
nothing to do with anything violent or
again they just weren't allowed to yeah
because that was one of the edicts I
guess yeah they didn't want the cops to
march congressmen and absolutely crazy
no that's not even close to the most
bananas famous groups and son just a few
weeks ago they were holding a protest
against Trump's Muslim ban and new
circle gali who is the head of Toronto
black lives matter one of them anyway
one of the co-founders she was on a
truck that was leading this crowd of
thousands of people with a crazy crowd
going through the streets of Toronto and
yelling like rise up fight back the
whole kind of chance and then she was
screaming at them Justin Trudeau when
everyone starts clapping her solo right
and they just like no don't clap he's a
good white supremacist and they're like
yeah like I don't know what the figure
they just clap when they're told to well
like that that's how crazy they are they
literally think Justin Trudeau was a
white supremacist and she's tweeted
things that she's like she's been under
investigation for tweeting out please a
lot help me not to kill all these men
and white folk out here and she is like
bleeding the Toronto black lives matter
movement yeah looks like a another echo
golly okay people heard it here first
I'm going to try to get her on the show
I suspect you will not I try to
interview her once but she just poured
glitter all over me I'm convinced that
it's like a mechanism that her counselor
told her to use when she wants to kill
why you go just like course litter on
them instead and we'll see try try that
would be glad someone attack urine
thrown on you is probably it looks good
people were talking you can lose your
eyes get it in there so but I looked
good at having worse in a little bit
yeah yeah yeah so where where do we go
with all this okay so you've laid out a
pretty good case for this stuff how do
you strengthen some of this stuff with
young people if it is it just the jobs
part like is it really like I I mean for
everybody not just the kids that are in
the inner cities but first in general is
it just keep attacking on the culture
thing because I do agree with you that
this stuff was starting to win I think
the thing that happened with Milo is a
net loss okay if he was winning the
culture part of this mm-hmm so is it
just that you just keep pushing on the
culture of art he still got his serious
support but I think that the
far left is doing more help to us than
anyone else I know that's not the first
time that's been said but I hear young
kids like in high school on the bus
talking about I've been like can you
believe in my classroom today they were
telling us we had to call this person or
whatever it's so crazy and like they're
talking about this they're talking about
the fact that they're being vilified and
hated for being white when I was in a
high school grade 12 they just
introduced social justice classes with
great when I was graduating the
introduced social justice class so
that's a very like very beginning of one
to some students use they took us out
into the hallway and they told us one
side of the walkers was a privilege side
of the walkers one side was the
oppressed and they were like men go to
that side women go to that side Asians
going to let's go to that side whatever
right and I told you you're privileged
you're oppressed we did privilege tax
can you find your skin color makeup in
the store oh you're privileged right we
did all this kind of stuff in this class
it was insane to me I think even a few
of the people in the class were like oh
I think that when that happens like
these young kids are like is it right
for me to be hated so much for my skin
color is that right and they go online
and they look into it and they find
people like Gavin they find people like
yourself they find people like Milo and
it's working the radicalism insanity of
the left and they're very very poor
arguments is working to help the right
and also the fact that our politicians
are not answering these questions that
are not going to go away the questions
about multiculturalism the questions
about immigration the questions that
these young people are very very curious
about and curiosity will always prevail
I think because yeah I hope so anyway I
hope it'll prevail and won't become a
North Korea situation but I these
questions aren't going to go away more
people are going to start asking them
and diversity is our strength isn't
going to work for much longer it can be
our strength as long as we tolerate
diversity of thought and as long as we
tolerate diversity of acceptance or
something but not just diversity of the
neighborhood total does the word I
caught up with quote on my Twitter I
think was Plato maybe a tolerance and
apathy are the last virtues
dyeing society because once you start
tolerating things like Sharia honor
killings once you start tolerating like
the ridiculousness of people like black
lives matter like yes let them have
their free speech but as a culture say
say no that's wrong we're going to speak
up against it we're not going to just go
and be apathetic about it or write think
pieces supporting it because we're so
afraid we want to be tolerant and don't
tolerate barbaric cultural practices
don't tolerate those kind of things
because you're afraid so I don't know it
depends how you use the word tolerance I
guess
all right well tolerance of intolerance
I guess yes yes yeah is there anything
about parts of the right either Trump or
Lipan or any of these people that
worries you at the same time that
worries me I mean they've been the thing
right now is it's such a like we need to
go with this now or we are going to die
situation right so the criticisms I have
of them like you look at Trump I didn't
understand why Saudi Arabia wasn't on
the ban and why Iran was instead I was
it must be Saudi lobbying I have an
issue with that but at the same time
he's still better than Hillary right so
I think we should definitely be
criticizing Trump we should definitely
be criticizing our disagreements but not
in the situation in Europe right now
with geert wilders and marine lepen
yet wait until you kind of help the
country and then keep your politician in
line make sure they serve the people
make sure they are appointed to make
sure they they do their job are the
servant of the people and not the other
way around
Yeah right so I understand why people
were so extreme in support of Trump and
not criticizing him especially during
his election to give it with a do-or-die
situation but now I think the people
that are very Pro Trump should start
criticizing him making sure he keeps his
promises making sure he doesn't become a
problem for the people as for the people
in Europe right now I'd say save your
criticism I know that sounds bad but
it's a do or die situation in my opinion
yeah do you think the days of the old
school politician are pretty much over
okay you know I heard just this morning
that now Oprah is considering running in
820 so we could have Oprah verse Trump
Hillary versus Trump wasn't enough for
us you know just that you know all of
these people they seem to be larger than
life now that just a guy who was a
really understood government who really
you know maybe work in the private
sector it was a decent home person and
good family why would why would you ever
want to get into politics number one but
number two you just never have a chance
because the Machine now wants something
that's so much bigger well I think what
you're going to say now absolutely I
agree the old politician is going to be
gone because you're some people shocked
that Trump is following through with his
policies that you presented here you
mean like he's actually building the
wall what politicians don't do that they
don't keep their bosses
what is this right I think the left are
going to be like we want a politician
like that to want someone that's going
to keep their promises and the right of
the right in other countries are going
to be like wow that's really cool he's
doing what he said he was going to do we
want that and they're starting to see
the model for how that works but they're
starting to be able to call out the kind
of polished establishment I you can tell
who is who they can tell who is being
honest with them and hopefully hopefully
that does kind of kill the old-style
politicians because it was getting
pretty pretty
exactly yeah who is this just not a time
for a libertarian so for someone like
you that I think has more libertarian
leanings the things that you're talking
about really the border stuff and all
that it's not really libertarian like
you need a strong government to do a lot
of that stuff so does that separate your
ideals from just the immediacy of now
right freedom is not free it has to be
defended and I like my ideal Society is
one without a government that would be
so cool is that going to happen in real
life no it's utopianist I'm not I'm not
going to live in a world where I'm the
view with book club Puritans pissed me
off so much as yell at you you're here a
state is seriously that's your status
well how are you helping the real world
dude like what kind of policies are you
implementing sorry Gary Johnson didn't
it is not going to win the election
that's a fact right right
I can't just disassemble everything I I
definitely I'm
classical liberal but I have a lot of
libertarian leanings but you can't just
magically make all these things go away
and expect the wheels to not come off
and as a yeah yeah implosion yeah that's
not like if you get rid of your
government what one's going to come in
and say hey I want this country or
enough immigrants are going to come in
and say hey let's make our own
government listen you know the freedoms
have to be defended and if you get
enough people in your country that start
immigrating there because you've open
borders whatever that hate freedom well
they're going to elect a very
authoritarian government so yeah you
need borders to defend me you need a
very very strong culture of freedom
first of all and you need to defend that
culture and make sure people assimilate
to that culture when they come into the
country because as soon as the freedom
lovers are overrun by the people who
want authoritarian far more
authoritarian governments they're going
to elect them you can't have you can't
have a very very extremist libertarian
purest society and democracy at the same
time you can't have open borders and
democracy at the same time you'll see
corporations importing voters to vote
for the politician that supports them it
would be insanity yeah and democracy's
not going away anytime soon in the West
so sorry like purists just got to work
within the system you've got and there
are people like Maxine Brunei in Canada
who's they call on a libertarian in the
mainstream media
you've got extremely libertarian
policies but he understands that the
borders need to be protected because we
live in a democracy though there are
logical ways to reduce the state
overreach but stay in the realm of
reality or we're going to have a bad
time a reality libertarian I guess it's
not that cat and I think that
nationalism is one of the best ways to
oppose big government because it's
saying bring things back bring things
back and the more people get
nationalists the more and more
nationalists they get they're like they
want because family is such a small unit
but it's the first nationalist unit I'm
going to feed my kids before I feed
someone else's kids otherwise my kids
will die and so my family line with it
the same goes for your city your
province your country if you don't help
them first then and you start giving all
your money away while your country dies
and so does its future so you need to
support the national scene
so take away from backups on the UN
backup from the EU focus on your nation
and then back up from the state focus on
your province focus on and get it closer
and closer to the individual you're
going to run for politics one day one
for office I did when I was 19 for the
Libertarian Party of Cruz I didn't get
very many votes because I was running
for the libertarians but um I don't know
it's such a toxic environment the people
in it I I mean you know you're in there
but it's so toxic maybe one day I'm very
young so got the whole world ahead of me
there you go well I'm glad that we
finally did this I think it was long
overdue and I didn't look down once
which I would say is the mark of a good
interview so thanks for coming in and
you guys can follow Lauren right on the
Twitter it's Lauren underscore exciting
thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]